[Music]
pennsylvania to me
is a white state
buddy um
again
i don't know what year you think this is
but i was just in philadelphia
quick marty
we gotta get back in the car
[Laughter]
and go back to 1488.
[Laughter]
you're not ready
you're not ready for this you're not
ready for this but your kids are gonna
hate it
quicker buddy
we need to go back to two weeks ago
before that dominican hookah took my
wallet you hear that this is your cousin
barry barry duke david listen to this
david you know that sound you've been
looking for well listen to
[Laughter]
of the this cities
okay i'm sorry
that would be if someone made if someone
made a back to the future parody where
racism only exists because of what marty
did
that would be the funniest thing on
earth it would be amazing the world's
perfect and then marty causes racism
dude
[Music]
it's like it's like it's like
circumstance like he's in this peaceful
town and then through like a whole bunch
of happenstance he gets his face covered
in soot and pisses off like a really
really like high-end executive
and racism remember back to the future
when the when the black like doo-wop
band
uh
gets the uh the guy he puts that gets
the guy out of the trunk remember and he
cuts and he cuts his hand getting the
guy out of the trunk maybe white people
saw that and they go wait are black
people violent because they took it out
of context and that's why there's racism
today because of marty mcfly
because of back to the because of back
to the future because of a doc dr david
duke brown
dr emmett david duke brown
why do you think he went back to the old
west he didn't work
go ahead
dr emmett david duke in quotations
mengele
brown
oh man
that's why we went back to the 1800s
because you don't want to be around any
black people
i'm the angel of death marty
[Laughter]
they should be in their own schools
marty that's why i'm back to the 50s
[Laughter]
quick money we got to go back to the
1800s and turn the boats back we got to
turn the boats back marty
so the flying delurian shows that shows
up over the amistad making him turn
around i'm sorry
grace says doc brown
is the funniest thing i've ever heard
oh [ __ ]
uh
yeah i know
family guy sort of did a joke like that
but ours was better yeah ours was way
better
[Music]
oh god sorry guys the only thing you're
missing is the confederate flag on top
of the [ __ ] time machine
no it's on the bottom so that the ship
can see it when it lands all right fair
enough
oh my god has someone done that a
delorean with a confederate flag
the general lee
hitting 88 oh yeah and when it jumps
that's when it flies
those big fly boys are at it again
when this
when this baby goes where this baby's
going we don't need
we don't need margaret singer
i'm trying to see if i can find a galore
i can't i can't seem to find a delorean
done up like the dukes of hazzard car
that needs to happen
confederate delorean yeah
i mean that has to have been done right
it's too
you would [ __ ] think yeah
all right i'm googling delorean dukes of
hazard let's see what comes up
let's see
okay no you just get the generally
what if anyone in chat owns a delorean
can you uh oh sure i'm sure somebody in
the chat owns a delorean
gates of above can you make your
delorean
uh
i don't think gates has a delorean
hey he has the money to request soar
every day how about think he hasn't
talked about this let's make this easier
can somebody just photoshop a
confederate flag on a delorean
just aren't there i think in the whole
state
is about 60 cities 50
60 cities of that i think
there's 10 black mayors
you know i do a lot oh my god you know
what i just realized in pennsylvania
you know what i realized pessy
guess what
doc brown look at his shirt
boogaloo boy
boogaloo boy doc brown oh [ __ ] and pit
vipers and he's got future pit vipers on
bro i'm telling you this is a real thing
and by the way the train shirt that he's
wearing you know where he got it dan
flashes
marty get in the passenger seat put all
those tiki torches in the back we're
going to charlottesville party
[Music]
hey doc why in the back are there
posters that say they will not replace
us don't worry about that barney
you're not jewish are you marty
[Laughter]
barney show me your penis
i want to make sure there's foreskin on
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay sorry guys
good music though back to future great
music
obviously the jew sent the libyans to
kill him
who is it israelis and they just shoot
up his car
all right man come on
marty run
we have to kill baby george soros marty
get in the delorean
okay enough guys
we're going to auschwitz
we're gonna find soros's mother and
punch her in the stomach marty marty
we're gonna go in time until and tell
hitler to adjust his train track so they
fit all the way through russia
why is alex joseph shut up the scooter
where are we going doc to
auschwitz-smarty to loosen the bolts on
the ferris wheel
hey doc why do they have a soccer team
and then at the end
the end of the movie
flies straight into the towers
[ __ ]
we've done it morty
we brought down the twin towers
[Laughter]
hey but what about oh geez doc but what
about the pentagon get back in the car
marty
god damn it
hey doc tower 7 fell on its own what's
that about shut the [ __ ] up party
here's a car
[Music]
gee doc i don't think you should be
kneeling on him like that john marty
hey doc
hey doc why are you making me wear these
cat ears in the passenger seat
what's that about don't worry get your
gold
why am i wearing why am i wearing these
caddies doc america first marty america
first mark
oh [ __ ] i'm crying okay okay
[Music]